The moment that I was introduced
to K-pop was on
Saturday Night Live
in April 2019,
when the group BTS or Bangtan
Sonyeondan appeared.
Being Asian American myself,
I hadn't realized how much
I had missed seeing people
that look like me onscreen
on a show that I had watched
since I was a kid.
There's a long history of
Asian American men in the media
either
being just completely invisible
or being deemed as not worthy
of romantic relationships.
So from a sociological
point of view, that itself
seemed interesting.
There are also articles
about how Asian Americans,
who always felt like they were
somehow ashamed or felt like
they weren't cool, that somehow
K-pop elevated their status.
My collaborator,
who is Korean, also said
that people recognize
his name as being Korean,
and suddenly
being Korean was cool.
When I was a kid,
if you had an ethnic name,
an Asian ethnic name,
people tried really hard
to change it.
The most popular person on
TikTok is a guy named Jungkook,
like he didn't have
to anglicize his name.
And so I never thought this
would happen in my lifetime.